summer series American wonders were
exploring places that make America
wonderful from majestic natural
landscapes to spectacular creations this
morning we go on board a historic train
bound for the remote Great Basin desert
in Northern Nevada its passengers are
not there to see sunny landscapes though
they're focused on the views after dark
CBS Sunday morning correspondent Lea
Cowen takes us for a ride on the star
train good morning for one of the least
populated places in the country aboard
one of the oldest operating railroads in
the country it's taking us deep into the
high desert in Nevada where the only
thing more scarce than people is light
these tracks have been here for over a
hundred years and to this day they're
about the only man-made things you'll
see way out here
if you leave eleaf there's a sign that
says next guess 164 miles and they mean
a hundred and sixty-four miles yeah Marc
Bassett looks the part of a railroad
manager he's the president of the
historic Nevada Northern Railway out of
dealing events a town built by this
railroad that is still chugging along
it's a long way from just about anywhere
though to come and you know that is our
strength and our weakness if we were
near Las Vegas right now that would have
all been bulldoze down but because of
our remoteness it was preserved these
trains have been running ever since
copper was discovered here there's no
more to halt any more but railroad does
offer passengers something as black as
coal nitride under the storm just before
sunset it heads out for a three hour
ride toward Great Basin National Park
certified is one of the darkest regions
in the lower 48 states no lights are
allowed way up ahead is Park Ranger
Charlie Reed racing the Sun to set up
telescopes before the train arrives you
just kind of let the sky do the talking
for you you don't you don't have to do
much for it because you once you see it
you see it and what the star train
passengers are about to see still
impresses even him does it ever get
overwhelming well tell you the first
time I came here first night I was
outside my house I looked up and I was
like oh no I can't find my marker stars
I can't find any of the stories I used
to navigate through upset because there
were so many
100 or so years ago a night sky like
this was oddly ordinary but now more
than a third at the planets population
can't see the Milky Way with the naked
eye all because our world is
increasingly polluted with light the
more darkness we lose we're gonna lose
the universe quite literally and all the
secrets that the universe holds as the
Train creeps to a stop passengers are
greeted by the eerie glow of red
lanterns what do you see from a young
man and then it happens the view of our
universe oh my gosh the way most have
never seen oh wow really mm-hmm oh my
goodness this is incredible I've never
seen the Milky Way in my life
Susan Titus and her 10 year old nephew
James were spellbound I couldn't believe
my eyes I've only seen things like that
in pictures sue Middendorf came all the
way from st. Louis for this view it's
just beautiful it really is it just
makes makes you feel so small like
fireflies gathered around a campfire but
soon it's time to board the star train
and head back an excursion into the dark
that for a while anyway sheds a little
light on our place in the universe
the race to save all of this darkness is
gaining steam but time is of the essence
as modern lighting becomes more powerful
and it becomes more cost-effective even
remote places like this one may one day
be in danger of living under what some
people call eternal Twilight wow what a
trip I know I want to go I want to take
my future steps in there that's crazy
you take Jack I'll take journey perfect
I got this next summer we're there